[Musik]
sieg im himalaya
der kleine indische bundesstaat war ein
einzigartiges experiment eine
landwirtschaft ohne pestizide ohne kunst
100 prozent bio
[Musik]
logitech in die rollen von der natur
nicht nur nehmen sondern ihr auch etwas
zurückgeben
in deutschland dagegen kommt der
ökolandbau nicht in schwung
warum eigentlich kann sich hin für uns
ein vorbild sein
[Applaus]
[Musik]
weg mit dem gift
im indischen sikh ihn kennen die
behörden kein pardon
obst und gemüse aus konventionellem
anbau sind streng verboten und müssen
vernichtet werden
schmuggler wollten dieses gemüse auf dem
markt in der hauptstadt verkaufen da
schnappte lebensmittelkontrolleur
passant ammann zu im namen der regierung
wir tun das um unsere erde zu schützen
und wir möchten der ganzen welt ein
gutes beispiel geben
dieses zeug ist nicht gut für unsere
gesundheit und auch nicht gut für die
umwelt
deshalb weckt damit solche
vernichtungsaktionen finden in sikkim
regelmäßig statt
der kleine bundesstaat rebelliert gegen
eine landwirtschaft die weltweit auf
pestizide und kunstdünger setzte sich im
ist die erste region der welt die
gesetzlich verordnet komplett auf öko
landbau umgestellt hat
[Musik]
sieg im befindet sich im nordosten
indiens mitten im himalaya und ist von
der fläche her etwa halb so groß wie
thüringen gangtok die hauptstadt liegt
auf einer höhe von 1800 metern
der bundesstaat gehört zwar zu indien
geht aber in der agrarpolitik eigene
wege
seit zwei jahren können die 600.000
einwohner nur noch bio lebensmittel von
den feldern sie kings kaufen
ich nehme ausschließlich bio
lebensmittel weil sie einfach besser
sind vor allem für die gesundheit meiner
kinder aber auch die erwachsenen nur öko
nahrung essen ohne pestizide
der deutsche bio landbau experte
bernward geier ist im auftrag mehrerer
internationaler organisationen für
nachhaltigkeit nach sikkim gereist er
hat den auftrag zu prüfen ist hier
wirklich alles bio
und wenn ja wie haben die sigma das
geschafft sein erster eindruck gut ich
habe jetzt gerade probiert er hat feuer
das schmeckt es ist besser wie er sein
soll
die möhren total frisch weist die bank
ist da noch im feld und für mich ist das
natürlich auch eine freude die frische
jetzt sehen die qualität die papaya sind
wunderbar da möchte man am liebsten
aufschneiden und reinbeißen
so soll bio sein gut aussehen es sind
sachen die sind gut aus frisch schmecken
viel geschmack haben das ist für mich
bernward geier soll beurteilen ob sie
kim für einen renommierten preis für die
beste zukunftsträchtige agrarpolitik
nominiert werden kann
eine woche lang wird er unterwegs sein
als gast aus einem land das wegen seiner
fortschrittlichkeit hier hoch geschätzt
wird deutschland
doch wie sieht bei uns der großteil der
landwirtschaft aus tausende tonnen gülle
auf den feldern pestizide kunstturner
wäre eine agrarwende wie in säcken
hierzulande überhaupt möglich georg
maierhofer ist konventioneller landwirt
in der nähe von passau rund 60 prozent
seines einkommens erzielt er mit der
produktion von pflanzen für biogas um
für die umwelt etwas gutes zu tun
verzichtet er beim anbau auf pestizide
eine komplette umstellung auf ökolandbau
die in syke hält er aber für unnötig
beide schienen machen absolut gesunde
lebensmittel und ich denke man kann mit
beiden lebensmittel 100 jahre alt werden
also das ist für mich
wir haben eine analytik die sehr genau
ist sehr genau wir können den kleinsten
rückstand heute nachweisen das ist klar
ob der dann auf die gesundheit
irgendwelche auswirkungen hat also da
bin ich sehr skeptisch trotz seiner
zweifel hat georg maierhofer ab und zu
auch mal ein experiment im bereich bio
landbau den raps den er für die
produktion von lebensmitteln anpflanzt
hat er in diesem jahr absichtlich nicht
gespritzt
heute sieht er sich das ergebnis an also
was man hier sieht ist ein befall des
grossen rats stengel röslers es ist für
mich als landwirt natürlich immer schwer
überprüfbar wenn ich
pflanzenschutzmittel einsätze ob es doch
die wirkung ist immer schwer zu
überprüfen
und ich versuche ja bisher neu auch neue
wege zu beschreiten und deswegen war es
für mich heuer eigentlich mal gerade als
bienenhalter auch so interessant zu
sehen ob es nicht vielleicht doch ohne
insektizide geht und jetzt kommen sie
auf den ertrag darauf an was ich jetzt
vom schädlingsbefall sagen kann glaube
wird sehr schwierig werden einfach so
auf bio landwirtschaft umzustellen das
braucht zeit erfordert viel geduld der
bauern
denn die böden und pflanzen waren
jahrelang an konventionellen landbau
gewöhnt
sein versuch mit dem raps kostet ihn 25
prozent ertrag im nächsten jahr wird
georg maierhofer wohl wieder spritzen
im geschäftsmodell des konventionellen
landbau sind ernteverluste nicht
vorgesehen
um möglichst profitabel zu sein müssen
die landwirte zusammenhalten und sich
organisieren deutsche bauerntag in
wiesbaden
hier ist zu sehen wie ein großer teil
der landwirtschaft in deutschland
funktionellen als großindustrie gelenkt
von interessengruppen die möglichst
keine risiken eingehen wollen und sei
offen für bio betonen die funktionäre
aber der ökomarkt sei nun einmal
schwierig wenn wir keinen vermarkter
finden oder wenn die ökologischen
lebensmittelwirtschaft sagt wir
importieren lieber ukrainisches öko
getreide als das deutsche zu nehmen dann
müssen wir natürlich damit auch umgehen
und wir sind ja nicht im luftleeren raum
unterwegs sondern der ökomarkt er ist da
er wird weiter wachsen aber sag mal eine
zentral geplante umstellung auf 100
das macht keinen sinn ökolandbau trifft
bei den meisten delegierten auf keinen
fruchtbaren boden
vielleicht auch deshalb weil der
bauernverband die nähe zur chemischen
industrie pflegt tatsächlich ist einer
der grössten pestizid hersteller der
welt auch einer der sponsoren des
bauerntages
wenn schon der größte lobbyverband der
landwirtschaft den ökolandbau nur als
nische sieht was sagt dann die
bundeslandwirtschaftsministerin dazu sie
ist ehrengast des bauerntages julia
klöckner möchte hessen zumindest ein
bisschen öko landbau werden wir ausbauen
das sieht man an meinem haushaltsentwurf
den ich vorgelegt habe wir werden jetzt
noch mal zehn millionen euro mehr dazu
geben wenn öko landwirte brauchen auch
rechtssicherheit und nicht nur
rechtssicherheit sondern verlässlichkeit
in sehr schwierigen an vier jahren
insgesamt will die ministerin für die
forschung im ökolandbau 30 millionen
euro ausgeben
vom gesamt etat ihres ministeriums von
sechs milliarden euro ist das gerade mal
ein halbes prozent
angesichts von enormen subventionen für
die konventionelle landwirtschaft kein
großer wurf
der mächtige bauernverband ist mit julia
klöckner zu früh eine agrarwende im
großen stil von der ministerin offenbar
nicht vorgesehen
[Musik]
trotzdem gibt es sie die unverdrossenen
die auf bio landbau umstellen wollen das
alte land nördlich von hamburg ulrich
beckmann war 20 jahre lang
konventionelle landwirte wir haben am
nächsten wochenende wieder regen
lasst uns doch vielleicht wegen dass die
vorlage neben den kragen seine
apfelplantage ist 50 hektar groß seit
letztem jahr wird das unkraut nur noch
maschinell bekämpft kein glyphosat mehr
keine pestizide
statt mit der chemischen keule
flächendeckend schädlinge zu bekämpfen
muss sich der frischgebackene biobauer
nun ausgiebig mit den abläufen der natur
beschäftigen
eine große herausforderung wir haben
hier lausbefall lausbefall ist
sicherlich im ökologischen landbau für
mich noch etwas neueres wir haben nicht
die möglichkeit die regulierung selber
zu bestimmen sondern müssen hoffen dass
die natur uns hilft und das natürlich
auch der nuz link in der lage ist die
schädlinge mit zu bekämpfen
im ersten jahr nach der umstellung
brechen die ernteerträge 1
das ist normal die eulen raupe und der
shop sind in diesem jahr auch vertreten
30 prozent weniger äpfel im ersten jahr
ein bitteres lehrgeld
man kriegt eine umstellungs förderung
die aber mit sicherheit nicht in der
lage ist das risiko aufzufangen
dh für das risiko müssen sie selber
sorge tragen und noch ein handicap in
den ersten drei jahren darf er seine
ernte nicht als bio verkaufen
der grund nach jahrzehntelangem
konventionellen landbau sind die böden
noch alles andere als ökologisch man
produziert zu den produktionskosten des
ökologischen landbaus aber ist in der
vermarktung eben nicht in der lage
zertifizierten öko ware zu vermarkten
und das bedeutet teurere produktion mit
nicht sicheren preisen um steller wie
ulrich beckmann bekommen je nach
bundesland geringe oder gar keine
zuschüsse
dieses problem will ausgerechnet ein
lebensmitteldiscounter lösen
eigentlich ist die branche dafür bekannt
die bauern in den preisen zu drücken
die rewe tochter penny möchte um stelle
betrieben unter die arme greifen und so
anreize schaffen und damit der
ökolandbau wächst der erzeuger der sich
dazu entschlossen hat umzustellen
bekommt erzielt bei uns einen höheren
ertrag für seine umstellungsphase als er
sonst am freien markt für konventionelle
ware bekommen würde deswegen
unterstützen wir ihm damit diese
mehrpreis diesen mehr preisgeben wir
auch im also im ladenverkaufspreis
weiter das bedeutet auch unsere kunden
zahlen für diese umstellungsphase etwas
mehr als für das konventionelle produkt
aber nicht so viel wie für die bio ware
für penny lohnt sich das programm der
discounter spart kosten indem er den
anteil an teurer übersehbare verringert
erst acht prozent der felder in
deutschland werden ökologisch bestellt
und das obwohl die nachfrage etwa nach
heimischen bio gemüse das angebot meist
übersteigt
[Musik]
zurück im indischen sikh hier wurde
innerhalb von nur 13 jahren die
komplette agrarwirtschaft auf öko
landbau umgestellt
66.000 bauern mussten umgeschult werden
der biolandbau experte bernward geier
besucht maler sherpa und ihren mann auf
nur vier hektar baut das ehepaar 16
sorten obst und gemüse an
eigentlich könnten sie auch nur vom
verkauf von blumenkohl brokkoli und
weißkohl gehen
es geht nicht darum nur eine reiche
gemüseernte 1 zu fahren sondern vor
allem um die gesundheit der böden
deswegen setzen wir auf eine
ausgeklügelte fruchtfolge das hilft der
bodenfruchtbarkeit wenn man immer die
gleiche kultur anpflanzt nimmt die
qualität der böden sehr rasch ab
deswegen setzen wir auf vielfalt
bis zu drei mal im jahr wird geerntet
auffallend sind immer wieder
mischkulturen es gibt eine haupt frucht
etwa blumenkohl und dazwischen andere
pflanzen die ihn stärken soll
das ziel ist resistente und gesunde
pflanzen zu fördern so dass schädlinge
und krankheiten keine chance haben
kompost stadt kunstdünger das gold der
bauern sind würmer unzählige tierische
helfer zu ersetzen den organischen
abfall zu natur dünger für die felder
hier geht es offenbar auch ohne chemie
seit sechs jahren hat es auf dieser farm
keine missernte mehr gegeben die bäuerin
ist umso erstaunter dass jetzt erstmals
ihr kartoffelfeld von einem pilz
heimgesucht wird
dieser kann eine ganze ernte vernichten
in sickels biolandbau sind solche
rückschläge keine katastrophe profit
steht für die menschen nicht an erster
stelle
trotzdem sind ihre ernten auf lange
sicht gut erzählen sie bernward geier
die gründe hierfür sind einmal die
vielfältigen fruchtfolge zweiter grund
ist die kompostierung das macht einfach
fruchtbare gesunde böden es kommen keine
krankheiten über den boden und natürlich
auch dass es starke pflanzen sind und
sie setzen
schwitzend pflanzen präparate auszüge
aus pflanzen quasi als heilkräfte ein
damit die pflanzen zu gesund sind dass
sie keine krankheiten bekommen können
die öko bauern in sikkim sind
selbstbewusst dass sie nicht weltweit
zahlreiche nachahmer finden erstaunt sie
vor allem wenn sie nach deutschland
blicken
eigentlich sind die deutschen doch in
der technologischen entwicklung führen
in deutschland gibt es großes wissen und
viele intelligente und vernünftige
menschen
ich frage mich warum sorgen sie nicht
dafür dass der ökolandbau in deutschland
vorangebracht wird
das sikkims bauern nur über geringe
schäden klagen hat vermutlich seine
ursache auch hier
das staatliche forschungszentrum für
ökologischen landbau neueste
wissenschaftliche erkenntnisse in
verbindung mit altem wissen das wird
hier seit 15 jahren praktiziert das ziel
nutzpflanzen noch besser zu schützen und
zu stärken
das erfordert von den bauern viel
engagement
sie bekommen mehr als 700 programme zur
weiterbildung geboten zum beispiel im
maisanbau dieser landwirt
schädlingsbekämpfung mit extrakten des
nehmen baums ohne nebenwirkungen für
nützliche insekten
für den biologen ravi kant abbas t lohnt
sich der aufwand
[Musik]
biolandbau fördert auch die
artenvielfalt
seit unserer agrarwende gibt es viel
mehr bestäuber und wie die bienen
hummeln oder schmetterlinge auch das
führt zu höheren erträgen die ernährung
der bevölkerung steht in syke man erster
stelle aber immer im einklang mit dem
artenschutz und dem erhalt der umwelt
hier im himalaya existiert mittlerweile
ein reiches wissen über den ökolandbau
die natur wird dabei als ein wertvolles
gut gesehen das es zu schützen gilt
dass ausgerechnet sie kämen als erste
region der welt auf 100 prozent öko
landbau umgestellt hat könnte auch an
der einstellung der menschen liegen
das hat bernward geier immer wieder
festgestellt
was bei der reise aufgefallen ist ist
die mentalität der bauern ist hier eine
andere
sie wissen dass sie teil der natur sind
und sie haben hat vielleicht auch mit
dem glauben zu tun her
sie haben eine achtsamkeit vor der natur
sie haben einen respekt und aus diesem
respekt können sie sich eigentlich gar
nicht vorstellen
gift einzusetzen agrargifte einzusetzen
kunstdünger einzusetzen eine
landwirtschaft frei von jeglicher chemie
das war die vision
ortstermin auf einer weiteren
forschungsfahrt institutsmitarbeiter und
bauern begrüßen den mann der sich hin
zum öko musterland gemacht hat
wahrscheinlich ist der dienstälteste
ministerpräsident in lienz noch immer
fährt der sohn eines bauern durchs land
um die menschen von seinem lebenswerk zu
überzeugen
denn anfangs war es für die landwirte
nicht einfach auf pestizide und
kunstdünger zu verzichten
mehr als 40 jahre lang war
konventioneller landbau für die menschen
normal sowie bis heute dem restlichen
indien schavan scham link brauchte einen
langen atem
es war sehr schwierig die menschen zu
überzeugen
besonders die bauer
sie haben lange an ihren einstellungen
und ihren alten gewohnheiten
festgehalten das war ein harter kampf
aber nach und nach haben sie schätzen
gelernt was bio landbau wirklich
bedeutet mittlerweile wollen drei
weitere indische bundesstaaten komplett
auf bio umstellen
pawan shumlin hat die menschen in sikkim
überzeugt das soll aber erst der anfang
sein
meine vision ist dass die gesamte welt
bis zum jahr 2050 auf öko-landbau
umstellt und dafür müssen wir
zusammenarbeiten für eine bessere
zukunft
wenn wir alle an einem strang ziehen
kann es wirklichkeit werden
das ist meine botschaft an die welt ob
die vision von covern schelling wirklich
in erfüllung geht hängt auch davon ab ob
öko landbau die menschen in den großen
industrieländern komplett ernähren kann
in frick in der schweiz gehen
wissenschaftler dieser frage nach auf
einer der anbauflächen wird seit 40
jahren konventionelle landwirtschaft
betrieben
direkt daneben felder mit öko landbau
ein wichtiges ergebnis des langzeit
versuchs die fruchtbarkeit des bodens
ist beim ökolandbau erheblich besser
für urs niggli den leiter dieses
weltweit einzigartigen großversuchs ein
zeichen dass bio pflanzen stärker und
vitaler sind als von kritikern gerne
behauptet beispiel weizen 40 jahren
stellen wir fest dass wir hier etwa 75
bis 80 prozent des ertrages des
konventionellen weizens haben und wir
sehen das auch als rein visuell dass der
weizen bestand sehr gesund ist dass wir
das unkraut problemlos im griff haben
und eigentlich ein äußerst erfolgreicher
weizenanbau beim bio anbau geht sogar
der schädlingsbefall zurück das haben
die forscher in einem langzeitexperiment
bewiesen
natürlich kann es auch mal schiefgehen
er hat sich der kartoffelkäfer von einem
bio pestizid nicht abschrecken lassen
auch wenn der ökolandbau von den bauern
viel geduld fordert wo es niggli
prophezeit der konventionellen
landwirtschaft schwere zeiten
ja die sackgasse ist dass man gewisse
probleme gar nicht mehr beherrscht
gewisse unkräuter sind resistenz
gegenüber die den erge ziegen gewisse
krankheiten sind resistenz gegenüber den
fungiziden die man braucht wir sehen
dass wir mehr bodenerosion
bodenverdichtung haben
und das führt dazu dass man dieses gebe
gar nicht mehr beherrscht sie sind gar
nicht mehr robust
für den wissenschaftler kann nur eine
landwirtschaft die menschheit ernähren
die die natur weniger ausbeutet der
ökolandbau
kurzfristig entscheidet aber der
verbraucher über bio oder nicht bio noch
kaufen neun von zehn kunden lebensmittel
aus konventioneller produktion wohl vor
allem wegen des preises
warum sind gemüse und obst die unter
einsatz von pestiziden und kunstdünger
hergestellt wurden so billig ein grund
ist sicher der preiskampf der großen
supermarktketten
doch das ist nur die halbe wahrheit
entscheidend sind die wahren kosten und
wer sie am ende trägt der ökonom adrian
müller beschäftigt sich mit dieser frage
schon seit jahren beispiel milch im
versuchsstadium schunk zentrums leben 24
bio kühe als futter bekommen sie
frisches gras von der angrenzenden wiese
jedes tier gibt im jahr 6000 liter milch
die art genossen aus der hochleistungs
zucht müssen bis zu 50 prozent mehr
milch geben damit es sich für einen
konventionellen landwirt lohnt diese
mehr produktion belastet die umwelt
die kosten dafür zahlt aber in der regel
nicht der bauer
um die kosten fallen einerseits schon
jetzt bei uns an zb wenn sie um
trinkwasser abbrechen geht für das wie
resident aufwerfen müssen wegen
präsentiert verschmutzung und so weiter
aus der landwirtschaft das sagen wir
direkt heute selber wenn es darum
importierter futtermittel geht zum
beispiel um die kosten darf und anfragen
dass die länder aus denen wir diese
futtermittel importieren also wir format
und das problem in andere länder
und wenn es sich um der klimawandel geht
dann tragen dass eigentlich alle
generationen also zukünftige generation
und ordnern die kosten die wir heute
verursachen was ist eigentlich rundum
ein schlechter deal auch für andere
agrarprodukte zahlt die gesellschaft
drauf britische forscher haben errechnet
dass für lebensmittel aus
konventioneller produktion mindestens
das doppelte gezahlt werden müsste wenn
alle kosten berücksichtigt würden
auf der anderen seite könnten
bioprodukte in zukunft auch günstiger
werden mit hilfe von agrar robotern und
satellitennavigation
auf einem feld in der nähe des schweizer
forschungszentrums wachsen 85.000
eisbergsalat köpfe weil herbizide im
biolandbau verboten sind musste das
unkraut bisher per hand gerupft werden
jetzt macht das ein hack roboter eine
infrarotkamera
und die sieht zwischen den salaten sieht
sie das unkraut und hat das mit messen
weg macht nachher auf dem salat und hat
wieder weiter früher mussten wir dieses
feld mit 25 leuten an einem nachmittag
machen
heute macht das eine person mit einem
traktor und einem haupt roboter der
prototyp benötigt noch eine
aufsichtsperson doch bald soll ein
völlig autonom ahag roboter die arbeit
alleine übernehmen
in ländern mit hohen arbeitskosten kann
die automatisierung sinnvoll sein in
sikkim wäre sie der falsche weg denn
hier arbeitet noch immer die mehrheit
der menschen in der landwirtschaft wie
hier auf den teeplantagen
der öko experte bernhard geyer besucht
zum ausklang seiner reise die größte
agrarfläche des landes in dem 177 hektar
großen garten arbeiten 400 menschen hier
wird einer der besten bio tees asiens
geerntet schäden gibt es kaum denn die
durch humus und andere nährstoffe
gestärkten teepflanzen sind äußerst
widerstandsfähig also was wir sehen
diese biologische anbau ist ein gutes
beispiel dass die möglichkeit in
einklang mit natur zu produzieren
möglich ist und wer immer behauptet ohne
chemie kann man keine landwirtschaft
betreiben ohne chemie kann man
sicherlich nicht so großflächige
monokulturen betreiben er kann herkommen
und wird eines besseren belehrt
nach der ernte bringen die pflegerinnen
den tee zur wiege station
sie bekommen wesentlich mehr lohn als
arbeiter im benachbarten der geely auch
weil die erträge mittlerweile sehr gut
sind
kurz nach der umstellung auf ökolandbau
war das noch anders
die ernte brach um zwei drittel ein die
an kunstdünger und pestizide gewöhnten
pflanzen waren zunächst schutzlos am
anfang gingen die erträge massiv zurück
aber jetzt mit zwölf jahren steigen sie
auf etwa 100 tonnen und jedes jahr wird
es mehr
ich denke in den nächsten fünf bis sechs
jahren werden wir wieder auf dem niveau
sein wie vor der umstellung auf bio
mittlerweile erfüllt der öko t sogar die
anforderungen der wichtigsten
internationalen bio zertifikat
[Musik]
für bartgeier endet hier die reise durch
den ersten bundesstaat der welt der
komplett auf bio umgestellt hat
[Musik]
ich muss wirklich sagen das was ich hier
erlebe ist weltweit einmalig auch was
die situation der menschen angeht die in
der landwirtschaft erleben sie werden
also auch nicht mit pestizid
konfrontiert die vorher auf die blätter
gespritzt worden sind sie haben einen
gesunden arbeitsplatz und man merkt den
menschen geht es gut es ist wunderbar zu
sehen mich stolz bauern sein können und
wir haben zu allen grund stolz zu sein
[Musik]
sieg im ist klein doch die vision ist
groß und vielleicht geben die öko
rebellen vom himalaya den impuls für
einen weltweiten umbruch
[Musik]